well as lake mead nears historically low  levels governor siselek is hoping that  everybody can work together to try and  keep the situation from getting any  worse  we need to do more in terms of education  in terms of  saving the water that we do have and not  wasting it now most of the water you use  inside of your house  is reclaimed it's put back through the  system it's put back in the lake we take  it back out again  but the water we use outside we don't  get back  right now the lake is just two inches  above a new milestone  low of 1070 feet one step towards  preventing a severe drought  pass through the nevada legislature and  it will remove what's considered  non-functional  turf that's grass that is never gets  stepped on except when it's  mowed